a wonderful pastor sees things in his
room alluded to grant what a talented
kid in lectern explodes to the rim he's
not the hunted he's the hunter this move
here that's next level raft of his big
time jr. only five shot attempts and
five turtles back to their patients
operation fadeaway unbelievable mama D
underneath great pass and finish since
Ashman and division warned that habit
triple-double
here's RJ down Duke impressive company
right there an impressive pool really
expanding his game at biani to the bench
nice kid and again inside mama D I would
not show any more ball screens on the
same thing but they do come back to me
they want to take a jump shot don't let
him in the light I know it sound and
what you do all year sometimes you have
to make a little bit judge this is you
keep giving this kid off until he's
ready to get back in
[Applause]
Spacely nice there you go huffing a pump
and a big hit delivery second round pick
of the Charlotte Hornets back in May
that's Jerome with the assist
that's his feel for the game Nikita but
pop in the middle turn draw that D
Lester that was a great close out there
hustling up the lane or the head guy
back out Arturo mile time and the basket
counts look at this bad style basketball
team we can make plays and finish the
mental anguish I'm sure they've had it
go through but all positive vibes right
now it's strong back outside with it on
the floor being in the right spot they
get one more slow recovery we found the
bull position pretty good effort they
generally don't hit that glass they
don't with it up gave up a short shot
patience back to row that's what they've
done nicely
with the pass Hunter had the right idea
that fast took a while to get there just
hit one from 25 they won't leave guy
such four-on-four
look at this drive Clark with the assist
the ability to make tethers but break
down again by Clark and why not ring the
bell big time
oh I'd love to be a blonde MIDI key and
Hough coming in 20 plug of this mess
what a pass inside to mama Dee he's got
eyes they are this kid right here the
first touch it jack it up I don't like
that particularly not against Virginia
to roam on the drive and two more for
the Cavs assuming control that's what I
thought he did the other night too
five to shoot
[Applause]
scoring is mamud d Raftery I love to
roam and hits patients there's a little
bubble and there's guys no yes wow what
a nice effort coming off a career high
nine rebounds against gardner-webb right
there he just wanted it more mama D
showing some image very athletic
big guy on the drive for two guy head
fake driving baseline I'll do little for
two so smart attack to close out Kyle
guy getting to the rim pretty easy to a
great pass baby but a better driving
finish meanwhile the suitor is only one
basket in the last six and a half
minutes too little
good huh but high up he's gonna stay at
this in goodness he's gonna be a great
contribute to his team now stick that
chest out and he's seven one with Lucas
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
like no one else can he takes us above
the rim and grant you know what they say
about the Akita
mama D mama do I'll tell you what he is
doing a lot with a fantastic finish by
the big fella appreciation for how they
plays how hard they work G with the
delivery but a great catch and mama D
continues his double play pretty good
Jerome gets the separation and knocks
down the three
Wow nice crossover get out and run here
something easy for the Sooners oh it's
not gonna be because Jerome look at the
past as he makes so any hand any tight
pass rate it is leadership by Jerome and
I mean just four on one fast break the
unselfishness a guy right here with a
little behind the bag we're now used to
seen that kind of sizzle from the fridge
in you can see the start of the game
they looked relaxed and more like
themselves it's a testimony to their
character too nice Mikey is better
finishes it off premium execution is the
calling card for Tony Bennett's
Calgon he is really struggled in this
tournament and that's a good sign for
him early tile guy gets his first jumper
[Applause]
kyle guy averaging 15 plus points per
game he is a light and find themselves
with another chance to advance to the
Elite Eight tied to bow country gives it
up drum inside DJ is hoping for a travel
on this play let's see no he kept his
pivot foot down the nice strong print
hunter little floater no taps it to
Clark another chance great pass no luck
and the two-handed Jam da ki jai
beautiful basketball by Virginia six
offensive rebounds seven offensive
rebounds from Virginia and one nice
double quarrel was the key to Oregon's
turnaround according to Dana off but he
was the one guy that was playing
selfless basketball selling off his
teammates finally hits a three now is
when Oregon needs to make a stand got
coming around on the curl
[Applause]
Clark another beautiful dish knocking it
down and we see Clark's the beautiful
bounce pass inside are not Oregon with a
little more since the urgency and
innocent last touch by to Rho by DT the
mean who hit a couple of big threes in
the first half you had that technical
foul he's got three fouls now and look
at what a floater this little tasty
floater you can't jump on it in that
ball the shortest middle of the court so
said this is a one-point game keep it
going get after the ball be the more
aggressive team
DJ pens one on the backboard here comes
the help and if he would've known he
could have thrown the loop-de-loop never
and dear Kate a pinning it against the
backboard
[Applause]
Jerome with Pritchard on him and here's
key hey Clark and an actor from the
freshman double-fist what that means is
man-to-man switching everything now they
could change it but right now that's
what they're really first 255 wins
here's to Rome now into the hands of
Jerome that's who they want a guy got
great ball handlers out here this is
what happens on the strap especially
when you're a little bit of frantic
[Applause]
score as well tied to Rome coming on 13
points took Perdue 99 points to in an
overtime game against Tennessee Virginia
won with just 53 points again
again @c Akita gets loose inside the
father-and-son legacy of the Bennett's
in the corner coming out of the timeout
not fair rebound ripped out by hunter
[Applause]
teen over the one UMBC owner Virginia
the Cavs have been able to erase that
when this sees now talked again by the
Akita he is
the place Virginia and Duke
remain his to roam tied to us with a big
by the way it's the first points by a
Purdue player other than Carson Edwards
since the 946 mark in the first half
that one is going to go to Rome a chance
at a three-point play this is the
patients at Virginian who take your time
no forcing a shot they really didn't
have assistant buckets in the first half
now though
haters [ __ ]
Gayathri
what a setup by Jerome and Kyle guy just
in the nick of time that is a record for
the first four games at NCAA tournament
history guy to the answer
[Applause]
Kyle guys first-team all-acc one-point
game Virginian to lead 0 for 3
yes tied to Rome extends the Virginia
Lee
sure mapped out the apt a wrench
a chance to live in here
[Music]
dear kids
dat tape he stands the town he floated
up over the outstretched arms of home
this is what you have to love this is
what the tournament is about
splits it drama pile the window he
scores what a [ __ ] buy tied to Rome
but on the other hand sharone get him
anywhere he wants to for the flip shop
he bonded the deity tape and honey
inside the office supports are there
goes to work on i-4 powers his way Dre
putter and Virginia now in the lead and
DeAndre hunter he's been quiet but two
big ones right there nice little duck in
but I know he's the guy that's gonna
beat you Chihuahua Jerome Wow it had the
smarts to initiate the contact on dumb
bar nice little kiss as you would say
coach little smoosh but they lift the
big guys gives them an opportunity to
kiss it home to call though they'd have
go a little bit ice ball screen
look at this defense hey coach against
Auburn you have to take the challenge
one-on-one defense doubled-up slams it
home nobody paid attention on the weak
side little more and that guy to keep
Virginia up 3c got them right out of the
gate really stepping up a lot more
pressure this is when you get back cuts
or open looks let me just get back what
is it sir you can't press them in the
half court
here's hunter much more aggressive yes
to start the second half and he gets
Virginia to Lee that's our eight lead
change of the game
McLemore the top score on the first half
nobody cutting it's the first five and a
half in DeAndre hunter showing his
defensive ability they're confrontations
interesting though that different
looking shot
look at this steel taken back by Clark
Keith does it his way always testing you
brow right in his picking his grill
every time he catches the tile guy to
roam in it's a seven-point lead the
largest of the game now is six to shoot
knows he can elevate it's the leather
short clock right here Jerome this takes
his time and off balance one hand and a
beautiful touch right there not the shot
that Tony befitted with his Bobby draw
up in a timeout they push attack the rim
at the other end now for Virginia the
second one two for a four-point lead two
possession game here for Virginia got a
gun for two right away they don't have a
speed guy to go to the rim not a hurry
now shot from the border goes down the
one with 6.5 11 for 11 from the line
against Kentucky how about this shot
though to keep him in it his toughest
shot all night Kyle guy knocking down
that three long pass 5.4 to go I think I
lost it for a moment
[Applause]
they had another foul to give
desperation shot from the other corner
81% he's tied it
this is unbelievable will the lead
they got all three budgets kind of
philosophy use those bumps keep busy
this kid can find people say off the
Jerome assess he really understands the
game waiting for him to come out of that
she'll all the mobs that good luck
raised outside defense
sure Owens is up to it tonight to take
those kinds of passes good job buffman
to get to the rent
there's guy that's a separation to the
show yep that's a two to Rome driving
outside he goes with it cluttered with
four only had time to roam stop in the
game play to perfection big time dribble
drive and fine just get the puppies
organized a Bayona prep a New Rochelle
45 minutes from Broadway the boys you
say low clock now with three hunter
does that set up his ability to use the
physique and attacked him rip stay at
home did you roam with to oneness shoot
some things he likes those short clucks
[Applause]
Sweetback hunter weights it seemed like
that might have been a time situation
that was closed said just great pursuit
really carving out area with a chance
for a number another one that's what you
expect from a given that tap
gotta go fast Jerome gives it up bar
side goodness with 12 seconds remaining
unearth continues with this great play
in the second half knocks down that
corner three and look what happens a lot
of great defense
sometimes over helps a good reaction is
it a dribble you're looking to help your
partner out put a wide open knockdown
jumper then bounce throw looking for
something to the corner Culberson and we
have overtime for the national
championship it's stopped on the
defensive end he makes a clean block we
got over times over buckle it up for us
they come back from three down to put up
five on answer to take a two pop lead
inside two minutes get that out of here
I'm full coverage and the reaction here
you see the emotion on the faces of the
Virginia players going to that mesh
they've got key say good night tuck sit
down eight points in front